heute machen wir das rettungsboot wars
ich glaub ich krieg' ich hin
doch wir werden schon sehen ich mein was
jubilars oma hinkriegt das darf ich doch
schon auch und was oder wie es richtig
heißt show kinosommer ist ein anime aus
japan natürlich und wie man aus dem
namen schon erkennen kann
geht es ums essen umhüllt von den sexy
anime klischees wie bild canon gibt es
auch viel nackte haut und übertriebene
reaktionen auf besonders leckeres essen
aber das macht den anime nur noch besser
denn schon in der ersten folge gibt es
viele what the [ __ ] momente und die
ziehen sich auch über die weiteren
episoden die geschichte ist einfach es
geht um den jungen talentierten juwelier
as roma der im restaurant seines vaters
arbeitet obwohl er schon ein sehr guter
koch ist schickt ihn sein papier aber
doch auf eine knallharte kochschule
damit er noch besser wird das so man
nicht auf den mund gefallen ist macht er
sich viele feinde aber auch treue
freunde sowie ein guter anime halt sein
muss die meisten gerichte sind sehr
komplex und erfordern viel talent aber
ich bin auf ein gericht gestoßen dem sie
komplett aus staffel eins folge 14
das noch relativ simpel wirkt dieses amt
ist sowas beitrag für die hotel aufgabe
in der er 200 eier gerichte an die gäste
verteilen soll
und wenn ich vorhabe noch mehr rezepte
aus diese manie mehr auszuprobieren dann
sollte ich doch lieber kleiner von oder
nicht mein gott ich bräuchte jetzt
eigentlich so ein band was ich vom ein
gramm ziehen kann und mir nicht stirn
legen kann moment es ist zeit für einen
schoko keks
[Musik]
es ist zeit für ein bevor das mich
heraus
gerade bei dem gericht nicht denn das
ist ja die aufgabe wie wie in ihre
prüfung bekommt 200 eier gerichte
verkaufen
lukas oma ist in der hotelanlage und
muss 200 eier gerichte an die prüfer an
die jury verteilen die mitarbeiter von
dem hotel sind er entschied sich für ein
komplett soufflé das problem bei seiner
entscheidung war das so ein eier um
letztlich ziemlich schnell ein singt und
dann nicht mehr so appetitlich aussieht
beziehungsweise seinen zweck nicht mehr
erfüllt flüssig und lecker zu sein lasst
euch schaut er hat ganz schön struggle
seine gerichte dazu verteilt und am ende
konzentriert er sich damit seine kraft
und macht halt einfach showkochen darauf
und da mir jetzt gerade auffällt dass
ich tomatensoße machen möchte werde ich
ein andere top anziehen denn das ist
[Musik]
meine transformation ist fertig wir
beginnen mit unserer tomatensoße die am
ende so beautiful drauf laufen lässt
werdet ihr jetzt nicht glauben aber mir
ist jetzt gerade eingefallen dass ich ja
in meinem kopf drin hab das ganze
ihr müsst mir das wirklich nicht glauben
es ist zu unglaubwürdig habe es ist so
und selbst da wo ich weiß noch als wie
das gekocht haben in meinem kopf hoch
sieht es zwar schon richtig schön aus
aber ich weiß dass ich da auch echt
gestreichelt habe und dieses soufflé
das ist so richtig so fertig aussieht
war wirklich schwer so die tomatensoße
können wir eigentlich komplett freestyle
machen ich habe in meinen kochbuch ein
rezept das wir damals entwickelt haben
aufgeschrieben und damit auch sagen die
tomatensoße die war
ich habe allerdings gerade keine
therapie soße dabei aber die hauptzutat
ist natürlich stöckige tomaten als das
stück youtube los ist und jetzt nehmen
wir es nur eine halbe dose von diesen
stücken tomaten und weil ich einfach
zurzeit ein riesen fan davon bin paprika
passte koreanische hat pep ist werden
unsere tomaten waren werden den wir uns
einen schönen teelöffel knoblauchzehe
das nicht fehlen die stehen einfach
meine knoblauchzehe mit der hand damit
die finger rede schön stinkender
nachteil in der mitte treffen und
einfach eingeben
ich brauche meine eigene kochschürze
meine blassblau kopfschutz habe ich bei
meiner schwester vergessen ein bisschen
salz rhein ein bisschen chiliflocken
überall muss auch pfeffer rein noch mal
schön verrühren
ich persönlich mag süße tomatensoße
deswegen mache ich einen schuss
ahornsirup rhein ihr könnt aber auch
honig verwenden oder rot so jetzt
probiere mir die ganzen spaß noch mal
rheingold die süße des auen sirups und
spielt an meinem gaumen völlig herum und
die schafe caprica soße gibt dem ganzen
noch den rest um euch einen eindruck zu
geben wie beifuß borsten essen
beschrieben wird weil sie es nicht
erkannt habt die soße ist fertig wartet
jetzt auf ihren einsatz und nun kommt
der star des heutigen tages dass
al-soofi komplett dort erwartet ihn
schon keks zwischendurch essen richtung
wasser trinken heute vergessen die börse
zu bringen
was ist los ist für das omelett julia so
beschreibt natürlich wie ihr das auch
net macht und dafür nennt er sah naja
und salz und pfeffer und öl natürlich
und hier ist es da des heutigen abend so
ein omelett drei eier
das war schon immer so ich mache über
die doppelte portion und dann kriegt
kino auch ein schritt hin und wieder
müssen die eier trennen glaube ich muss
euch nicht sagen
ein neuer trend wenn ihr das im
hauswirtschaftsunterricht noch nicht
gelernt habt dann stimmt etwas nicht mit
eurer schule selbst wenn ihr kein
schlechtes gewissen beim eierkauf haben
wollt dann holt euch die eier die eine
null am anfang haben in die eier kommt
jetzt eine prise salz und ab die post
so unser eines stellen und nun machen
wir das gleiche mit dem eigelb das wird
zwar nicht schau nicht so dass einmal
leute ich wusste was mich aber tommy
girl zum nestlé kauft das mich noch mal
versprochen
vergessen war das war natürlich alles so
geplant haben
also das ist ein bisschen aufgeschlagen
und nun gehen wir sahne dazu und
schlagen zu ende auf so und nun haben
wir unser eiweiß und unsere eigelb sahne
mischung das verwöhnen lässt vorsichtig
und manchmal so der dort ist steif ist
kommt jetzt da ein
fühlt sich ein bisschen wie backen an
ganz vorsichtig wir wollen das nämlich
so fluffig wie möglich behalten
ich glaube das ist richtig
manche nächster schritt fahne aufheizen
und öl in die pfanne wir müssen noch
nicht so ganz damit sparen wir wollen
hier dass es gut wird von dem trend
haben wir nämlich viel zu wenig öl
genommen ja dann versuchen wir unser
erstes dinge dass hier wieder alles
finden sich in einem feld kaum nach
ich mach mal einen großen ich hab mir
das irgendwie logica vorgestellt könnte
zur posaune bläst was ist das mit mir
und einer gerichten dauer funktioniert
es nicht
deckel zu und warten bomba alles auf
eine karte
er selbst habe ich einen kleinen gemacht
und den angeschaltet wenn wir das sind
dicker geworden ist habe ich so ein
riesenteil sieht auf jeden fall sehr
crazy outback somit wäre es denn die
jobs und gegen monster schaffen er
schlug sich ganz geil aus also das ist
es am netz es ist zum glück nicht
verbrannt es ist nur sehr dunkel
natürlich servieren wir es mit unserer
tomatensoße und undefinierbaren frischen
kräutern und das ist das komplett
abzuklären um der pflege und nun stellen
uns natürlich wie das allerwichtigste
frage warum bin ich so verschwitzt und
wie schmeckt das soufflé omelett ist auf
jeden fall extrem
so sieht ein bisschen aus regelt extrem
rum ist es glaube ich aber durch also es
war ja im heißen dampf eigentlich müsste
es jetzt auch save tui sein team bis in
tomatensoße
das ist der perfekte beiträge lecker
geil
es verläuft im mund wo hört sich das an
es ist so fluffig und chemie
[Musik]
oh mein gott das ist echt als ob man
beim essen würde es ist so schade wenn
man es in den mund nimmt dieser läuft
ist schaue mich und lenkt das ist
einfach weg ich meine ich habe es ja
schon mal gemacht habe ich habe beim
kochbuch auch nicht so schlimm gekommen
war war wach und das war das zu viel
geld aus putbus wenn jetzt mal selber
nachmachen gold kommt ein kochbuch oder
versuchst einfach selbst es ist sehr zu
empfehlen ein wirklich jetzt macht voll
spaß es zu essen
bis zum nächsten mal natürlich